without objection the chair is
authorized to declare recesses of the
committee at any time we welcome
everyone to today's hearing on oversight
of the US Department of Justice report
by special counsel robert muller the
third on the investigation into russian
interference in the 2016 presidential
election and related matters I will now
recognize myself for an opening
statement
attorney general Barr has informed us
that he will not appear today although
we worked to accommodate his concerns he
objects to the prospect of answering
questions by staff counsel and to the
possibility that we may go into
executive session to discuss certain
sensitive topics given the Attorney
General's lack of candor before other
congressional committees I believe my
colleagues and I were right to insist on
the extended questioning to my knowledge
not even the ranking member was opposed
to the idea of moving into closed
session if necessary but even if
Democrats and Republicans disagree on
the format of this hearing we must come
together to protect the integrity of
this chamber the administration may not
dictate the terms of a hearing in this
hearing room the challenge we face is
bigger than a single witness late last
night the Department of Justice wrote to
inform us that they will ignore our
subpoena for the unredacted Mullah
report and the underlying evidence they
have made no meaningful attempt at
accommodating that subpoena which was
due yesterday the letter references the
Attorney General's offered to 12 members
of Congress 12 out of 435 to look behind
some but not all of the redactions
provided that we agree not to discuss
what we see with our colleagues and that
we leave our notes behind at the
Department of Justice it is urgent that
we see the documents we have subpoenaed
but I cannot agree to conditions that
prevent me from discussing the full
report with my colleagues and that
prevent the house from acting on the
full report in any meaningful way an
accommodation designed to prevent us
from taking official action
is no accommodation at all every member
of this committee Democrat and
Republican alike should understand the
consequences when the executive branch
tells us that they will simply ignore a
lawful subpoena from Congress it's left
unchecked this act of obstruction will
make it that much harder for us to hold
the executive branch accountable for
waste fraud and abuse or to enact
legislation to curb that kind of his
conduct or any kind of misconduct no
matter which party holds this chamber or
the White House at a given moment
challenge we face is also bigger than
the Mullah report if all we knew about
President Trump were contained in the
four corners of that report there would
be good reason to question his fitness
for office but the report is not where
the story ends in the days since the
Department of Justice released the
redacted version of the report president
Trump has told Congress that he plans to
fight all of our subpoenas the average
person is not free to ignore a
congressional subpoena nor is the
president his promise to obstruct our
work extends far beyond his contacts
with the Russian government and
allegations of obstruction of justice
the president has also prevent us from
obtaining information about voting
rights ACA litigation and his cruel
family separation policy among other
matters the challenge we face is also
not limited to this committee in recent
weeks administration witnesses have
simply failed to show for properly
noticed depositions the secretary of the
Treasury continues to ignore his clear
statutory obligation to produce the
president's tax returns the president's
private attorneys sued chairman Cummings
in his personal capacity in an attempt
to block the release of certain
financial documents ladies and gentlemen
the challenge we face is that the
President of the United States wants
desperately to prevent Congress a
co-equal branch of government from
providing any check whatsoever even his
most reckless decisions is trying to
render Congress inert as a separate and
co-equal branch of government the
challenge
we face is that if we don't stand up
then together today we risk forever
losing the power to stand up to any
president in the future
very system of government of the United
States the system of limited power the
system of not having a president as a
dictator is very much at stake the
Attorney General of the United States is
sworn to uphold the Constitution as our
nation's chief law enforcement officer
he has an obligation to do everything in
his power to warn the president of the
damage he risks and the liability he
assumes by directly threatening our
system of checks and balances and of
limited government
sadly the Attorney General has failed in
that responsibility he has failed to
check the president's worst instincts he
has not only misrepresented the findings
of the special counsel he has failed to
protect the special counsels
investigation from unfair political
attacks he has himself unfairly attacked
the special counsels investigation he
has failed the men and women of the
Department of Justice by placing the
needs of the president over the fair
administration of justice he has even
failed to show up today yes we will
continue to negotiate for access to the
full report for another couple of days
and yes we will have no choice but to
move quickly to hold the Attorney
General in contempt if he stalls or
fails to negotiate in good faith but the
Attorney General must make a choice
every one of us must make the same
choice that choice is now an obligation
of our office the choice is simple we
can stand up to this president in
defense of the country and the
Constitution and the Liberty we love or
we can let the moment pass us by I do
not and we have seen in other countries
what happens when you allow such moments
to pass by I do not know what Attorney
General bar will choose I do not know
what my Republican colleagues will
choose but I am certain that there is no
way forward for this country that does
not include a reckoning with this clear
and present danger to our constitutional
order history will judge us for how we
face this challenge we will all be held
accountable in one way or the other and
if he does not provide this committee
with the information it demands and the
respect it deserves
mr. bars moment of accountability
come soon enough
and now recognize the ranking member of
the Judiciary Committee his opening
statement
Thank You mr. chairman let's be very
clear there is only one reason and one
reason only at this point we are not
being able to fulfill our constitutional
role of oversight and that is the
Chairman's demands that were played out
yesterday we could had a hearing today
what bothers me the most about this is
not only did in standing for the
questions that were discussed and the
issues had been discussed between me and
the Chairman not only did he take the
ability for the American people to hear
again from bill Barr
he took our ability to hear from bill
Barr today to protect maybe because some
didn't feel like they could ask proper
questions maybe it wanted more staff
questions who knows but yesterday we
found this that he claims that he wants
staff questions south that question the
Attorney General because the five-minute
per member is not enough but yet we
spent it in approved a motion yesterday
that said we could do a whole hour
an extra hour between the chairman and
myself
he could have taped one of these
fabulous members that he has and he has
some excellent attorneys on his side
some of the best he could have give them
all 30 minutes and they could have
questioned the Attorney General any way
they wanted to instead we go back to a
circus political stunt to say we want it
to look like an impeachment hearing
because they won't bring impeachment
proceedings that's the reason take
whatever you want to take you can go out
and have press conferences you can say
to from this dice you can say whatever
you want to have but the reason bill
Barr is on here today is because the
Democrats decided they didn't want him
here today that's the reason he's not
here you could have done anything else
she wanted and what is amazing to me is
to say that he is scared of answering
questions to scare that it on you can
disagree with the Attorney General all
you want but for yesterday he's set for
over almost six hours in the Senate
voluntarily asking questions even on the
second
Roundy was taken up by Democrats who
wanted to ask more questions and you can
agree did he do good did he do bad it
doesn't matter but we're not getting
that opportunity today because the
stunts and the circus continues over
here all we had to do
we agreed to more time we can talk about
executive session but no for some reason
for some purpose except the optics of
something they can't do or don't want to
do right now they wanted to have a staff
member asked questions I said before if
that staff number wants to ask questions
are decimally run for Congress put a pin
on find the committee but you know I can
continue on and on and on about the
issue that we have here in the
impeachment agenda and whatever you
wanna have in saying that he's
blackmailing this committee is terrified
to come before this committee I think
yesterday he proved he's not terrified
to sit before anybody especially the
Senate which they actually extended the
question time on he answered the
question whether you like the question
oddities my chairman told me yesterday
it's not a matter what we agree or
disagree on this we have the motions we
move the motion we do the motion you can
agree with the Attorney General or
disagree with the Attorney General but
not hearing from them is a travesty for
this committee today but I would be
remiss if I also did not mention the
largest tragedy of this day it actually
was from yesterday
the Chairman just stated a few moments
ago that we can't let moments pass and I
agree completely
because what happened yesterday on this
dice was a travesty when you do not
recognize members for valid motions when
you call things dilatory questioning the
motives of what members are doing it
forward I have said on this committee
for six years and I have sat through
hours of motions to strike the last word
of giving other members on the minority
side more time more time one of my
biggest concerns I ever had with
chairman Goodlatte is why do you let it
continue
just call the previous question and on
to a quote toe two equations last
Congress he did over our resolutions of
inquiry after almost six to seven hours
of debate the question I have here is
not what bill Barr scared of my question
is what are the Democrats scared of they
don't want bill bar here today they've
had the report they've read it they
don't like what's in it the Chairman
won't even go look at what the Attorney
General offered him it's pretty amazing
to me he wants to go into executive
session and ask questions about it but
he won't go read it
now you can go read it and ask for more
but here's the problem today and this
problem from yesterday is not over if
the majority wants to run a committee in
which minority rights do not matter
parliamentary procedure does not matter
we saw it on full display yesterday it
will not continue we will continue this
in exercise and we will exercise what we
have as minority which is the minority
rights to ask questions to make motions
because at the end of the day unless
we've forgotten mr. chairman you've got
more votes than we do you will get what
you want but just like we said on this
side and you said on this side and got
to spend hours talking about whatever
you wanted to talk about while chairman
Goodlatte set there and let you do it
and all you wanted to end the question
that bothered me the most yesterday is
we got time we got to get onto another
bill timing does not Trump minority
rights and there's not a member on this
guys this should say it's not and
freshmen members or anybody else who's
here for the first time that's not how
this committee works if you don't
believe me ask chairman sent some runner
for three times three times was chairman
of this committee and he laid it out
clearly yesterday but when we degra gate
members of my side calling miss les COEs
amendment ridiculous calling ours
dilatory that's just wrong and should
offend every body on this das mr.
chairman
this is wrong the tragedy of today is
not that you have an empty chair not
that you have props you can call the
Attorney General whatever you want you
know I was reminded of sticks and stones
kind of quote well what really bothers
to me today is is the travesty of what
happened in minority rights yesterday
and there's not a member of the
Democrats who are on this committee last
year they can honestly look me in the
face and say y'all were not treated much
better by a chairman who actually
followed the rules then we were treated
yesterday I yield back
Thank You mr. Collins ordinarily at this
point I would introduce the witness but
instead but instead we will conclude
this proceedings I just want to say we
didn't choose not to have mr. Barr come
he chose we will we cannot permit him or
anybody in the administration to dictate
the manner in which we function this
does not include our inquiry into the
Attorney General's handling of the malla
report for Nepal our inquiry is conduct
before Congress nor does it conclude our
seek recognition compelled introduction
of the entire report and its underlying
materials we will not hear from the
Attorney General today but this
committee intends to obtain the
information that it needs to conduct its
constitutional oversight and legislative
responsibilities we will defend the
prerogatives of Congress we will defend
the rights of the American people to
know what's going on we will defend the
constitutional scheme of equal and
coordinate branches of government we
will make sure that no president becomes
a monarch we need the information
without delay the hearing mr. chairman
and we'll do so with trampling minority
rights it's gonna be mr. chairman we're
there there is not going to be a
recognition of members who seek
legitimate inquiry as to the procedures